now to the debate over abortion rights
in this country after the Supreme Court
chose to keep a commonly used abortion
pill available for now this case has
exposed another political Rift between
Republicans like Donald Trump and Mike
Pence on an issue that has long divided
this country Jan Crawford has more
the Supreme Court's ruling leads the
abortion pill mifa pristine available
without restrictions
the political fight over abortion as a
campaign issue is intensifying I'd like
to see this medication off the market
former vice president Mike Pence who is
weighing a presidential run in 2024 told
CBS news's Robert Costa that access to
abortion shouldn't just be left up to
the states he is pushing for Action at
the federal level says Congress should
pass a nationwide ban on abortion after
the 15th week of a pregnancy more than
90 percent of abortions occur before 13
weeks this is an estate's only decision
I think the American people would
welcome a minimum National Standard but
that puts him at odds with former
president Donald Trump who says Congress
should stay out of it other Republicans
say the GOP should be careful with its
messaging ahead of the 2024 campaign
season we're going to lose huge if we
continue down this path of extremities
the brief unsigned order from the
Supreme Court Friday night is the most
significant action involving abortion
rights since the justices overturned Roe
vs Wade less than a year ago but the
issue is likely to be back before The
Supreme Court next year after the lower
courts weigh in on the merits whether
the FDA followed the right steps when it
approved mifa pristown 23 years ago and
made it easier for women to get it in
2016. Friday's emergency action with
just two of the nine justices dissenting
suggests the court is unlikely to block
access to the drug the next time around
there are significant questions about
whether the challengers even have
standing to bring the case
now Justice samuelito wrote a dissent
saying he didn't think the court needed
to even issue this emergency stay
because the pills still would be
available but that doesn't really tell
us anything about how he will see the
merits of this case I would not be
surprised if he joins with a majority to
say this case never should have been
brought in the first place Gail all
right Jan thank you very much